la verità scomoda che mia nonna
scoreggia tutte le rotte faccia mente di
non sentirla aggiunge voglio chiamare
richiamo alla nonna
ciao ragazzi bentornato nuova puntata di
vita buttata il tema della puntata di
oggi è verità scomode questo video in
collaborazione con il iad che già da
subito conquistati sia perché ci sta per
permettere fare una cosa che volevamo
fare da un botto di tempo e che
finalmente riusciremo a fare e si apre
il suo claim che è legato alla
trasparenza ossia la verità fa crescere
è una cosa nella quale credo e crediamo
tutti quanti all'interno di questo
canale bisogna dire le cose anche quando
sono scomode perché qualsiasi cosa che
noi nascondiamo in realtà è un piccolo
tarlo che rischierà prima o poi di
distruggerci quindi tanto vale parlare
tanto vale mostrare a tutti quanti chi
siamo perché se non lo facciamo vuol
dire che abbiamo qualcosa di cui
vergognarci ecco perché ho pensato
invitare all'interno degli studios di
casa mia
mio fratello enrico e di cose ne sa
forse fin troppe su di me ciao a tutti
ragazzi è bellissimo comunque noi siamo
sempre abituati a ascoltare i vostri
messaggi a sentirli spesso la nostra
domanda è poi ecco perché oggi in campo
entra lui e per la prima volta avevo
chiesto su facebook non so di mandarci i
nostri messaggi vocali ma abbiamo
chiesto anche il numero per poterli
eventualmente chi ascolterà remender
scriverli in giro negli autogrill olanda
ciance ho parlato fin troppo partiamo
subito la premessa attualità rizzi che
dorme lumi non dormi perdi verità
scomode gli ho ben due la prima è che
avendo la classica babyface la gente mi
prende sempre per una persona dolcissima
quando io invece serbo grande rancore
per la maggior parte della popolazione
umana e la seconda è che sono napoletano
non mi piace la mozzarella no siamo
lassù subito chiamiamo l'epec lo chiamò
la helem andiamo là di quelle catene che
sono dei virus
la mozzarella la mozzarella o tutti i
formaggi ma io te l'ho dato la
possibilità di dire tutte formaggi
atella che non piace
[Musica]
un'altra domanda quindi hai la faccia
super buona carina dolce ma quindi
adesso sembrerà ancora anche per me dai
ti mandiamo un bacio grande io ci ho
provato
ci ha provato io saprete tutti i
formaggi e latte no aspetta che la
segnaliamo anche io sono napoletana non
mi piace la pizza napoletana pazzesco
per quella romana se io dovessi mai dire
una cosa del genere in pubblico
probabilmente mi ammazza certo quello
americano quell'altra molte già per
barbie augusta medico a riyadh ambita
che ci siamo ho assistito in diretta a
nola sono ragazzi avete salutato mentre
un po più seria che tendo a ricordarmi
tutte le password di conta luther
cellulari quindi qualche volta potrà
essere entrato in telefoni e di amici è
una cosa che portate che ha detto che ha
visto la mia craniata l'ha visto cosa è
successo veloci si simula c'era una
vetrina unità perfettamente non l'ho
vista ci sono entrato dentro di kranj o
dovrei avere anche dei reperti
fotografici che ora mettiamo lento e
dentro il locale mi riconosce un tavolo
ciao cui riconoscersi nei se non ne
prende il mio telefono di natale con il
suo collegamento poi dopo è diventato
negli affari ma mettete diciamo come
gestire la vicenda che maniera la fedra
si apre un dibattito cosa pensate
riguardo a un'azione di questo tipo a me
fanno più paura le persone che
tradiscono il rimangono
nell'azione già se c'è un tradimento
significa che sotto sotto la persona con
cui stai non va peggio è un problema hai
sbagliato a tradire ma non era forse un
avvisaglia del fatto che gli stessi bene
lo aspetta la quadra di al natale la
palla festa della famiglia del ragazzino
odio la pasta non mi piace la carbonara
non mi piace la matriciana non mi piace
la vasca al sito mi fa proprio vomitare
se proprio me la devo mangiare mi
piacciono le bende riunisce tonici bonci
gruppo ragazzi possiamo mettere un like
se vogliamo che questa ragazza aperta la
nazionalità italiana tutti cipolle buono
posso capire che magari possono piacere
le pene di morte mangiare penne ricci ma
noi invece la pasta ma se proprio deve
enrico ti prego torna qui questo però
non è un vocale lei ha vinto retto
secondo giorno con il nuovo coinquilino
in casa i rom per il telefono
gentilissimo mi presta il suo che non
avrei trovato una soluzione al problema
lo accendo vado su google succo della
storia troppo come vado in a predefinita
di chrome il suo account di pornhub a
contatto di foto profilo gigantesca
presso e che amano ma che foto profilo
devi mettere su pornhub e quante
gigantesca grande concluso quanto era
grande questa foto profilo è la mia
eroina sappia io voglio un troppo opera
parete io invece vorrei farmi un po
snervante fidanzato e
mentre innamorato di se vuole ascoltarlo
perché la prima è il tricot non ho
capito ma innamorato di te le madri come
lo chiamai subito ciao come stai
crede che gli ottimi gusti da dire una
cosa però che non puoi anche usare la
scusa di testico calcetto perché l'ha
pregato i ragazzi mi ha mandato un bacio
grande come la chiacchiera e jessica
calcio devono scrivervi a proposito di
verità scomode di vita buttata e la
verità è che io ho 17 anni tra vanno in
gita a parigi dimentico delle scappa la
pipì e arrivato il momento di rendere
l'ascensore per andare sulla torricelle
no ho fatto la pipì c'entra la scintilla
della torre che non ci credono affatto
bene amato rispetto a cagare non è
proprio essere mai stato a parigi
fisicamente è ti da un impatto diverso
normale ferro doveri non è che sia
chissà che costruzione ed esame da
scomode alcune d'accordo con i ragazzi
lavori pelle eran penali ed dice cosa sa
la verità fa crescere in questo momento
la verità fa male
sono costretto cucinano ogni volta che
sono a casa della mia ragazza con la
scusa che non mira che ci stanno tutte
che lei non sa cucinare quindi lui per
non dire alla ragazza guarda non sai
costiero ci pensino tranquillo no no
tranquillo ti preoccupare e caruccio dai
pensa quanto vicino a modena ma mica
posso dare un consiglio a questo ragazzo
è un consiglio certo mamma mia
subito lei e la satta in cui g
[Musica]
ma aveva cucinato tu io qui ho enrico
che m'ha detto che amano perché gli devo
parlare io per dargli dei consigli
non so che cosa voglio dirti secondo me
dovresti andare a fare tv un corso di
cucina insieme ma per riscoprire i per
riscoprire nuove emozioni ma tu non ci
ha mai pensato di dirglielo papa mentre
mi accingevo a pulire il bagno di casa
la testina dello spazzolino elettrico
del mio coinquilino mie accidentalmente
caduta nel battersi lava ancora i denti
con questa è cattiveria vera una volta
che l'ha fatta credere che hai fatto
apposta per lo spazio del 20 chi ha
detto di metterli in azione
io ho detto il mio deve essere me paola
perego la ragazza che frequenta da mesi
ma che è stato però che di dieci anni fa
mio primo vertice un fatto storico
completato detto pelè lontani e
nonostante adesso vada tutto alla grande
anche la ball punto di vista all'epoca
era tutto tranne che un bravo giocatore
di golf vi sono genova ma il tesoro
avuto insomma se mi chiamerebbe e io in
forno vento sta con lui allora mi sa
trascinante rimarranno un gene stato ma
il nostro
il ragazzo sa fare marketing però se ci
sta insieme da dieci anni significa che
questo giocatore di golf prima o poi
diventato il tiger woods che ha per lui
mammamia guglielmo e angelo d'angelo di
pallacanestro pronto lo so ringraziamo
iliad si può parlare oppure l'aquila e
1000 partite non c'entrava l'obiettivo
accedeva dall'ombelico allora abbiamo
due aperture sulla delle sue ma tra la
terza creata diciamo tramite l'unione
io sono per questo che stiamo parlando
di una materia che io non conosco la
terza perdurare cosce no non ci credo
lei non è venuto a dieci anni dopo come
va la situazione lunga vita al re
sono stampa romana del ragazzo di una
delle mie migliori amiche che poi
imbeccata magari sa soltanto che lui
l'ha tradita con murdered e mesi quando
in realtà la cosa è andata avanti per un
anno era un medico intini abbastanza per
questo ciao
[Risate]
secondo il bambino cose che mi fanno
arrabbiare hanno poi magari si
organizzano la cina
queste persone o spunto non sono la
minestra o nel segreto della pasta
oppure rivetto leccare le posate e
piatti e le persone che andranno a
mangiare per niente una ragazza
ricreativa per chi non lo sapesse di con
serio problema che schizzinosi stimo una
follia quindi allora ricordati che io
abbia rarissima che si ritrova in
pochissime persone al mondo la paura
della frutta finché intera dicendo non
mi dà fastidio un po mi mette ansia però
nel momento in cui non so qualcuno si
mette a mangiare una pesca o aprire una
prugna io mi sento male perché inizio
anno iniziano le palpitazioni respiro
male quindi devo uscire dalla stanza ma
davvero amaro un po mettiamoci come
immagine del profilo tipo un frutto ti
prego non è cattiveria macedonia andava
in vacanza qualche giorno ad amsterdam
mi sono presa un pacchetto di biscotti
insomma non biscotti normali capiamoci
tornata a casa li lascia in cucina la
mattina seguente non trovo più i
biscotti ma trovo i miei in cucina
addormentati in un sonno profondo
oltre russa la fame dei trattori per
causa mia non sono andati al lavoro
perché tipo dormito quattro ore non
riuscivo a svegliarli lui proprio
liberale si è mangiato degli scritti di
scottato al gas tra i tuoi non hanno mai
scoperto niente elementari in estate e
facevo pp dal balcone nonostante avessi
bagno che ne oltre la porta d amore mio
lo facevo da piccolo che una volta pure
l'ho fatto quindi gabriele lo facevamo e
lanciato montesi ne esca in marcia via
di qua destro parlato se quelli dei
piani su comunque ragazzi siamo arrivati
alla fine di questo video io ringrazio
ancora il grande sia per averci dato la
possibilità di fare questo esperimento
fateci veramente sapere qua sotto se
potrebbe essere una cosa che ti farebbe
piacere vedere anche in futuro ma
soprattutto ringrazio i read per il
coraggio e per aver citato proprio carta
bianca per trattare anche un argomento
un pochino scomodo la verità è scomoda
deve notare a volte scomoda ma bisogna
sempre dirla perché fa crescere
iscrivetevi a questo canale se vi è
piaciuto questo format attivata la
campagna notifiche per non perdere gli
altri video che usciranno noi ci vediamo
domenica con una puntata di cucina tutta
tanti cocente grazie noi ringraziamo
anche quasi che per la prima volta per
lo schermo per la prima volta
ciao ragazzi un bacio ciao